3 slimani conseillère municipale de la
ville dormant le principe de précaution
aurait dû être appliquée je sais pas si
c'est madame busin où l'ensemble du
gouvernement je crois qu'il ya eu en
tout cas effectivement un
dysfonctionnement majeur de ce point de
vue là une faute de l'état qui a voulu
encore une fois tellement rassuré la
population qu'elle la mise en danger
puisque lll a expliqué qu'il ne se
passait rien que finalement c'était
juste malodorant comme si on était
d'ailleurs des des personnes
particulièrement délicate armand qui ne
pouvions pas supporter une odeur mais
évidemment quand vous sortez une odeur
c'est bien que derrière il ya quelque
chose c'est d'ailleurs un mécanisme
humain assez assez connu donc voilà
effectivement il ya une minimisation en
tout cas de ces risques
alors que la ministre est que les
ministres le gouvernement et le préfet
n'avait à minima pas la connaissance de
savoir si c'était dangereux ou pas dans
es donc il n'était pas de leur ressort
en tout cas il ne devait pas dire que ça
l'était pas puisque dans ces cas-là on
applique le principe de précaution et
c'est vrai que le principe de précaution
n'a pas du tout été appliquée lors de
cette catastrophe